(slow rhythmic hip hop music)
- Unforutnately, the
theme of my life.
My next book should be
called "Drinking with Drago."
- Good, tight grip.
Feel the chests,
tight upper back.
Yeah feel the lats, come on.
Good.
Let's go.
- The Gary Vaynerchuk
(announcer inaudible).
(crowd cheering)
- [Man] Gary.
- Morning.
- [Audience] Morning.
- I grew up a humongous New York
Knicks fan and I actually hate
Michael Jordan
with my entire heart.
I was in the wine business and
then I went into be an agency.
I'm in B to B now.
One thing I learned about
B to B is it easier than B to C.
It is.
It's easier because your
fundamentally actually know the
name of the fucking
person you're selling to.
It's Rick Thompson
from Microsoft.
It's not fuckin' brain science.
How many people B to B here?
Yeah, fucking jackpot.
(audience laughs)
One thing that
I'm very worried about, very
worried about is that I
believe this is a
room full of transactors.
This is the roomful
of people in sales.
Not in business building not
in brand building,
not in marketing.
Salespeople.
And by the way remember
how I started this talk.
This is not me looking down.
I'm a salesperson.
I am a salesperson that ran
direct mail and radio and local TV
and outdoor billboards
and Google Adwords.
I bought the word wine on Google
Adwords the day Google Adwords
started for five cents a
clicking I owned it for 9 1/2
months before anybody bid me up.
Because that's what you
do you day trade attention.
You buy underpriced assets while
everybody's overpricing it.
Like today.
March 9 only because the
book came out yesterday.
March 9, 2016
I know that for a lot of
people in this room that
do digital scalable tractional
B to B if you're running Google
Adwords and affiliate
marketing that you don't.
Individually some of you
may but I'm looking at
the overall behavior.
Because they are not
practitioners in Facebook
marketing they are headline
readers in Facebook marketing.
Yeah standing O mother fucker,
standing O mother fuckers.
You got it.
Good to see you.
- Doing alright?
- Yeah.
- Are you awake?
- I'm awake.
Once you get on-stage
the adrenaline takes over.
- [Man in dark blazer]
That was great, Gary.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Man in dark blazer] Thank you.
- Yeah, let's do it real fast.
- [Man in dark blazer] Keep it up.
- Thank you.
- The woman next to me 45 years
old, downloading Snapchat and
adding you first--
- It's the game.
- How good is that?
- It's the best.
- Keep it up, man.
- Thank you, brother.
Thank you.
- I want to get DRock in
on this damn picture here.
- I'll see you again.
- I appreciate it.
- Awesome.
- Stay well.
- Nice meeting you.
Enjoy the book.
- I like the shocking value. I've
never heard of you before until
today I'll admit that.
- Well, thank you.
- I love it man.
- Thank you, brother.
Good luck to you.
Stay well.
- We'll get you to
sign these in a minute.
Let's get a
picture real quick, ok?
- Let's do it.
- Our parents are Colombian,
we know the whole immigrant.
- [Man] Gary, I saw you
this morning 6 AM in Atlanta,
that's why I'm here on Snapchat.
- No shit.
- That's how I got here.
- Amazing.
See you soon, brother.
- Hey man.
Luis a real pleasure.
- Likewise.
- The Barnes &amp; Noble's,
yeah, baby.
I got us focus on.
- I've been
following since Daily Grape.
I'm a huge fan of your work.
- Thank you, brother.
- And besides the books that
about for other people,
I want to give you
value anyway that I can.
- Thank you, brother.
- Write go to fucking work.
- You got it.
- That's what I want.
- I'm stoked, Gary.
- Oh, we're on video.
- Yeah, that's
what were doing.
- Fuck, I wasted three
seconds, I'm sorry.
- It's okay.
- How are you?
- Dane.
- Dan, how are you?
- No, it's Dane.
D-A-N-E.
- Got it.
- Can you tell my Snapchat
followers that you called me Dan
though because
it's a big joke.
- This is crazy, I just called
Dane Dan and I actually I'm
actually just going to
call you Dan from now on.
Is that all right?
- That's the best thing ever.
- Dan.
- Thanks man.
- Finally hanging
out with GaryVee
- Kyle finally for me, I'm
finally hanging out with Kyle.
- That's what's up.
You heard it here
first everybody.
Thanks, buddy.
- Good to see you bro.
- Good to see you, too.
- Thanks for all
the interacting, man.
- Yeah, no problem.
(conversing in Russian)
- Is your dad proud?
- Yes, of course.
- I'm 42 from
Russia as well.
- Where?
- St. Petersberg.
- St. Petersburg
it's an amazing city.
- Same story kind of.
- When'd you come over?
- I came over '95.
- '95. Yeah, of course.
- Thank you.
- You're a legend man.
- I hope you enjoy it.
Stay well, brother.
My man, I wish you well.
Keep hustling.
- Thank you, yes.
- Be patient you're young.
- Okay.
- Be patient.
You've got time.
- After hearing you today I
was like alright, that's it.
I'll jump on.
- Broke it down.
- Do you want me my first snap?
- Yeah, hell yeah.
- Okay, I don't know
what the hell I'm doing.
- You're doing good.
- So I reverse it.
- Yep. This is your first Snapchat.
- You're my first Snapchat.
- What do you want
to say to everybody?
- Hi Snapchat, this is GaryVee.
- I'm GaryVee.
(woman laughs)
- Oh my God--
- Oh, I love it.
- I didn't know about this.
I forgot about this.
- There's a Rainmaker frame.
- I forgot about it.
I forgot about it.
- Your crazy oxygen here.
- Thank you.
- Started watching
the show in July.
- Yes.
- Since then I'll directly
attribute $2 million dollars in
growth in the business to just
mindset and tactics
but mainly mindset.
- One more time, brother?
Josh, tell 'em.
I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, DRock.
I know you got it.
- Awesome man.
- Thank you, thank you, that is
exactly what I'm trying to do.
- You're helping people, Gary.
- I'm trying, brother.
- Hi.
- I'm Catherine.
- Are you Catherine?
- Yeah.
- Lean in, lean in, lean in. Hey.
- I want to say thank you
brother because I sent you an
email if I while back if I can
do a one-on-one with you,
threw myself out and
you responded--
- Yep.
- and that's totally bad ass.
The amount of attention that
you give, I really appreciate it.
- I'm trying man.
(slow, rhythmic hip hop music)
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
- So you all did a great job.
This was amazing.
- [Man] Thanks for coming out.
- Take care.
- You're leaving at 1.
- Okay.
- So we'll do a quick lunch
and we got some folks that want
to ask you some questions.
- Let's do it.
- You got through for everybody.
- Yeah, that was a good job.
I thought that was a really good
job by you to make that happen.
You got my phone?
That was the right move, my man.
- In opposition
to the intro move.
- That was so perfect.
That made it so fun.
- I'm sitting next to Brenda
and I said he's going to hate,
going to hate the
on Michael Jordan.
- I had no clue.
I've watched you speak
a bunch of the times but I
never heard that piece.
- I don't talk much about it.
It's common man.
What's cool though is
there's nothing better than
getting punched and getting up.
'Cause when you get up,
there's that scene in every
movie where like, every movie,
there's that scene in cliché
movies where the guy gets
punched directly in the mouth
and he just turns spits his
blood out, looks the guy
back in the face.
I live for that in business.
I live for that.
- [Man] It's Rocky IV.
- Yeah, I live for that shit.
Is it Rocky IV again?
I feel like Rocky IV
is taking over my life.
- [Man] What doesn't get done?
- A hundred things.
Everything.
I'm not crippled
by being at a 60.
If I didn't work on my
personal brand Tennessee would
have two more clients
because I would help things.
But if I didn't build a brand,
would we close something without
even doing an RFP?
Things, all of them.
I'm not crippled by anything
that is a vulnerability or a
shortcoming or a loss.
I'm literally basically the
1990 Layola Marymount
basketball team.
I'm trying to win 172 to 163.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- I'm such utter
offense, got it?
What's good is, what people
don't get is, this is good for
you two here, I believe you do
that early, like early, and then
as you get maturity use money
to do what the Broncos did and
build your defense.
And I think way too
many people play defense
too early in a company.
You don't parent a kid that is
three and four the same way that
you parent a kid
that is 16 and 17.
And some people try
to run businesses as if
their kid is 17 and 18.
There like reading fucking Jack
Welsh books or their dad did in
a certain way and they
think that's maturity.
In the first 5 to 7 years as
long as you don't go out of
business if you can grow
top line revenue,
that's pretty much what
you should be doing.
When you walk why one of your
employees' desk and you can
feel in your stomach that
they're having a bad day,
you should investigate it.
Like I don't know, I know that
something intuitively in me that
I know that other
people don't have.
(slow, rhythmic hip hop music)
So appreciate the one-on-one snaps.
(inaudible) Thanks
for everything you say.
It matters, thank you.
How are you guys doing?
- Snapping it up,
snapping it up.
GaryVee in here.
- Snapping it up, big J.
Who should we make fun of?
Hey Lazaro--
- All of them.
- And Morin.
- Gary, Todd (inaudible).
- Todd.
- How are you doing?
- Real pleasure.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, thanks for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Woman] Can I do this for you?
- Yes.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Yeah, let's do it.
That's the best part.
- Wait, wait, wait
let's get a shot.
Is that a video?
- He's doing
the DailyVee thing.
Have you started
watching DailyVees yet?
- No, should I?
- DRock, should he start
watching our DailyVees?
- Thumbs out?
- Thumbs out.
Awesome, I'll
see you in there.
Hello, hi pretty girl.
Hi Elaina. Adorable.
Is she okay with some of the
potty words that might happen?
- Oh yeah.
- Okay.
- How you been?
- Good man, how is everything?
- Really good.
- You'll be here for two days.
- Yes.
- So I'll probably
see you tomorrow.
- I hope so.
- [Man] Midterms?
- [Gary] Midterms?
Thank you guys.
Sup?
- [Audience] What's up?
- Where's the fire?
- For the fireside chat?
I'll bring some fucking fire.
(laughter)
- Oh, I was told there
were families and
children, I'm sorry
that was a poor decision.
(laughter)
- I spent five, six, seven
years now eating shit.
I mean it.
Going from where I was
financially, and all the
opportunities that I had my
life, the idea to then go and
start a client services
business and go to meetings with
associate brand managers who
go to Babson and tell me how to
sell shit, fuck you.
I absolutely have deployed
enormous amounts of humility and
patience in the last five or six
years which is why when I meet
youngsters or even people in the
40s or 50s I always push those
attributes yet nobody wants
to deploy them 'cause are not
attractive and they're not
quick gratifications but they
absolute pillars of success.
- My name is Xenon.
I am from Istanbul.
- [Gary] Very nice my man.
Do you know that dude?
- No, I don't know him.
- [Gary] You guys
need to hug it out.
(laughter from audience)
I love it.
- First, I think I'm
slightly obsessed with you.
Not in a clinical degree.
- [Gary] I appreciate that.
I'll repeat this for you guys.
- When you said on DailyVee 19
people are going and starting
businesses out of college and
haven't even sold anything in
the lives and I was an
athlete before I got injured.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I think I have my idea
but maybe I was meant to be a
manager or leader but I'm not
sure which one I'm supposed to
be in that ties
into self-awareness.
- [Gary] It does.
- I was wondering what's your
opinion, maybe you say it's
entrepreneurial--
- [Gary] So, I'm glad you asked
this question, you know, I think
when you're as young as so many
of you are I think what you really
need is to think about a more
holistic patient strategy.
I think in a first five-year
window of hitting the
marketplace, I think the much
smarter selfish thing to do,
'cause the selfish thing
to do is to start a company.
I had a funny meeting, I don't
know if you had one of these yet.
I've been telling
the story lately.
I had a meeting the other day
with a kid whose business is
going out of business.
It's over. Lost.
Couldn't raise his next round.
'Cause that's
what gonna happen.
None of these people
actually built a business.
They built a financial arbitrage
machine that was built to make
the next raise happen and
keep going until you either got
bought or something
good would happen.
So they didn't
build businesses.
The startups
aren't businesses.
These startups are machines that
were built to raise more money
through users or other things.
So were sitting there and
he's like, "Yeah man it's
over." He's really whatever
and I have a sad face because
I'm compassionate.
(audience laughter)
And he sees it and he goes,
"Oh Gary, don't worry man
like I learned a lot."
I'm like, "I'm not worried
about that, dick.
I'm worried that you lost
150,000 of my dollars."
And what he doesn't know is that
what we do as VCs and angels for years
is we talk about all these people
and see how the navigating
or they're not and your
reputation is much more valuable.
And so it's important for
self-awareness and I think the
selfish thing to do is actually
go live a five-year blueprint
where maybe you do try to start
something the first year out I
think it's a great thing
to do you get to learn
something about yourself.
Maybe you going get
a job for two years.
I think interning, for real,
like a full pledge
I'll give you real, real value
and I'll do it for nothing but
I really want to be like you.
If you want to be like a hip-hop
mogul a business person, it's
really a good idea when you're
22 it makes a lot of sense
especially of mommy and
daddy are on your side.
And you can afford it, it's a
really good idea to hit up all
55 hip-hop mogul executives in
the world and be like I will
work for you for free for 15
to 18 hours a day because I can
tell you this, Phil Toronto,
Nate, Playa, DeMayo, my personal
assistants become beasts because
they're so close to it.
DRock's getting
smarter by the second.
(laughter)
It's true.
Yes dear.
- Hi.
- I'm keeping diaries of CEOs--
- [Gary] Okay.
- Two questions:
First one what is your
secret to greatness?
- I would say empathy.
- And the second one,
when Gary hits rock bottom,
what brings you back up?
When you really hit it.
- Gratitude.
(applause)
Empathy allows me to
really care and think about what
you're thinking and and that
healthy and sales and that helps
me be likable, it helps me
navigate, it helps to make
decisions about
products and services.
It helps me so much.
And gratitude because I never
really fully hit rock bottom in
a business context.
The only thing that will ever
make me hit rock bottom is the
sickness or death of
somebody I love.
There's nothing else.
There's no deal.
I don't hit rock bottom when
(bleep) and I couldn't work
together anymore because they
wrongfully made their only KPI
YouTube video views for 2015.
I went out and got
(bleep) as a client.
I don't hit rock bottom when
somebody when I love and admire
and want to build around
has to leave my company for
circumstances that
neither one of us can control.
I adjust.
I make the best out of it.
In business, I never hit rock
bottom because I have business
squarely pegged
were deserves to be.
Which is the health
and well-being of
my friends and family,
the New York Jets, business.
(applause)
Thank you.
Love you bro.
- All right, awesome Gary.
- Take care.
Where am I going?
My man.
- I just want to make sure
that you knew that I was here.
- Good to see you.
- I'll see you in
New York soon, alright?
- Yeah. Doing well?
- Great.
- Did you enjoy it? Good?
- Always.
- Good to see you.
- Gary, thanks so much
for coming out here.
I'm a big big fan.
I've been watching and
listening to your
stuff since Crush It!
man it's been a
great pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Can you sign my book and
take a quick selfie with me?
- Yes.
- You're the man.
- Sid, what's up brother?
- Rock on. Cheers, bro.
Thanks so much I
really appreciate it.
- You got it man, stay well.
- It's my dad's birthday
tomorrow so would you mind
saying happy
birthday to him real quick?
- Yes, what's his name?
- His name is the Vinayak.
You've just got to stop that.
- Vinayak, It's GaryVee.
I'm here with your son, he's
good-looking which means you're
good-looking. Have the
best birthday ever man.
(crowd laughs) Take care.
- I'm actually from
(inaudible) New Jersey.
- Get out of here.
That's awesome.
- I love that.
- Request, would you mind
putting me in a headlock?
- Yes.
- Wrestling fan--
- Thank you man.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you For coming today.
Really appreciate it.
- His name's Patrick.
- Patrick, it's GaryVee.
Jen's excited.
Where the fuck are you?
- He moved to Connecticut.
- That's close, dick.
(Jen laughs)
- Gary, thank you so much.
- Do you mind taking a
picture with the two of us?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- What you said about
bootstrapping Gary.
- Bootstrapping
is the game, man.
Even if the economy was
phenomenal, bootstrapping is
better than raising money.
You own more of your business.
It's so crazy how good venture
capital and that world has
convinced people that
that's the route.
I know everything
that makes them tick.
I reverse engineer everything
that they want in life.
Money, fame, hanging out, work
life balance, I figure out what
they care about.
That's how you do it.
- Quick photo right here?
Nope.
- Blurry.
- One, two... Oh,
video, you know what?
- Video, oh shit.
what's up?
Follow me GaryVee,
follow me GaryVee.
- Thanks Gary.
- One of these days when
to get this man to join the
board of my nonprofit.
- Kevin, I believe you but you
going to have to crush,
your going to have to be patient,
you're going to have to be
persistent and you're
going to have to not be soft.
- That's easy.
Alright, man.
- Good to see you.
Good luck to you,
good luck to you.
- Paul, how are you?
- Can you draw
clouds and a dirt?
- Yes--
- Focus on the clouds in the dirt.
- Yes.
- Look at that.
- [Gary] And then a tree.
And a sun.
Not bad.
That was pretty good.
- That was quite impressive.
- [Sabrina] Now just do show.
- You do the India part?
- Yeah, I'll do the India part.
- Alright, you want me
to do the whole thing?
- You ready?
Sabrina, are you ready for?
- I'm ready.
- [Both] Let's
get into the show.
- Good job.
You got it.
Take care.
Stay well.
- No, no, no worries.
Here with GaryVee.
- Oh shit, all you guys
are into video, huh?
Yo, follow me GaryVee.
- Hey Sam, it's Gary.
You are very sweet.
And I am the best Vaynerchuk
sibling, not my sister.
- (laughs) That's awesome.
- Hey man, Cal.
- Cal, how are you man?
- Good.
- Right, there we go, good.
Good.
Awesome, take care Carl.
Really nice to meet you.
I hope you enjoyed tonight.
- Thank you. Yeah, I did,
I had a great time.
- Thank you brother.
- Thanks.
- Bye, darling,
great to see you.
Thanks for coming.
- Thanks very much.
- You're welcome.
Awesome.
Guys, thank you so much
again for all your help.
Really means a lot to me.
Thank you, thank you.
Continued success, I
hope you enjoy the book.
- I did very much.
- Gary, what's
going on my man?
- Doing good, my man.
- I'm Meech, nice to meet you.
- Mich, love that name.
M-I-C-H?
- M-E-E-C-H.
- Meech.
- I saw you last
December started watching.
Kinda killer.
- Good for you.
- Thanks man.
Awesome.
Meech, thank you so
much, man. Take care.
- Thank you.
Good to see you again.
- Always a pleasure, Gary.
- Thank you man.
I know our selfie is done
so I know are in good shape.
- But, long story short
it's going to be a drive.
Let's get dirty.
- Dude, you're young.
I mean... Nobody
wants to be patient.
Be patient.
You got nothing but time.
How old are you?
- 27.
- Yeah, you've
got nothing but time.
- This ages me a little bit.
- You've got nothing but
time, way more than you think.
You could do nothing, nothing
right for four years and you be
nine years younger
than I am right now.
- The thing that gets me is you
see so many different people--
- They're fronting.
- No, no, no, I see
my friends like--
- Oh, that's different.
- getting married, kids,
house, duh, duh, duh.
- Okay.
- I'm not there.
- The second you start letting
outside shit be a factor,
the second you're losing.
I don't give a
fuck about anything.
Try, try.
- Thank you.
- I wish you well.
- Hi Gary, how are you?
- How are you?
- Are we now in your crew?
Is this like... Is this
what's happening now?
Is this what happens?
- Real pleasure.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You got it.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet
you, I'm Breanne.
- Breanne, how are you?
- Good.
I have a question for you.
- Please.
- I'm in educational
technology I have a company
that's making a smart toy and
I heard that you Kevin told me
that you invested in a
smart toy company--
- I did. I'm looking at
another one right now.
- I don't have a
question for you.
I'm just awestruck.
- Thank you so much.
Actually let's get in here.
- Sure.
- What's your name, young man?
- Thank you.
You made my day.
- It's good to
see you, brother.
You ready to
rock 'n roll soon?
- It's good that you're
in Boston, I'm excited.
- Your flight got delayed today.
- Yesterday.
That was already yesterday.
That's how much fucking
shit has happened in 24 hours.
Meech, it's GaryVee.
My man, it's time to put up
or shut the fuck up.
Get up big man, get up!
- There you go.
Every morning, every morning.
Thank you so much.
(slow rhythmic hip hop music)